salut tout le monde ici podcast
envergure épisode 36 ça y est les boules
de loto ont été tirés nous ont donné
l'ordre de la draft la loterie c'est
peut-être dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi en france et on peut maintenant
donc évoquer les stratégies des équipes
en haut de la draft et pour cela appel à
un ami du podcast fred hoff deux
programmes fin connaisseur de la nba
tout simplement parce que c'est son
métier et sa passion
rémy réversion de binh sport est avec
nous salut rémy est jamais content de
vous retrouver
désolé j'affiche les couleurs parce que
vous comprendrez qu'on a enregistré ce
que la juste avant la finale absolument
on enregistre sage le dimanche rémy quel
est ton envergure c'est une question
rituelle
oui c'est une bonne question je crois
que j'ai jamais fait mesurer alors moi
je mesure 1 mètre 94 g des longs bras
donc je dois être au dessus je dois être
un bond aux médecins dans la guerre je
pense un mètre 94 de médecins qu
d'envergure il ya du joli prospects est
bien acceptée accepté et romain vous le
voyez pour ceux qui nous regardent en
vidéo romain est là qui est je le
rappelle est le président créateur de
l'association compte le flotteur en
france l'utilisation
j'ai encore eu le débat l'entraînement
il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça et bien
tout simplement on va dérouler le fil
des équipes
maintenant qu'on à l'ordre de la draft
on va se projeter le soir de la draft je
vous explique un peu le concept très
rapidement et c'est très simple une
franchise après l'autre on est en deux
clics
alors petit podcast petits moyens j'ai
ma petite montre et ça va être trois
minutes par équipes trois minutes par
équipes
rémy jouera le gm romain le directeur du
scouting
moi je serais très modestement adam
silver et à la fin des trois minutes il
faudra me donner une décision est ce
qu'on draft ou est-ce qu'on traîne le
pic et si on draft quel profil allez si
on veut être précis quel joueur ou draft
avec avec avec quelle franchise quoi
quels joueurs on associe à quelle
franchise
etes-vous prêts messieurs
je suis mais donc le premier choix de la
draft est arrivé à minnesota et donc
comment comment on va on va gérer ça je
lance le chrono contexte à minnesota
qu'est ce qu'on a envie d'avoir à
minnesota
rémy la parole est à toi alors je suis
donc gm de minnesota donc j'ai de la
chance d'avoir le premier pic de la
draft c'est si une période compliquée
parce qu'on sait que la franchise était
plus ou moins en vente
la question c'est est ce que ce sera
toujours le cas avec explique qu'il fait
prendre de la valeur
mais d'abord la franchise quoi qu'il en
soit les mecs doivent penser à ce qu'ils
vont faire et que ce pic si une
franchise qui est quand même en
perpétuelle reconstruction autour de
carlan tony tan dis donc il ya quelques
incertitudes autour de 10 ans jane
russell est ce qu'il est là sur le long
terme pas j'ai l'impression que c'est
une équipe qui toutes façons avec ce pic
la doit aller chercher le meilleur
talent disponible qui ne sera pas dans
la raquette parce qu'on va pas mettre
quelqu'un dans les pattes de 40 c'est un
peu débile au quai romain
ça tombe bien en haut de la draft alors
s'il ya un profil qui peut se détacher
un os de la draf avec james wiseman qui
est plutôt un poste 5 mai - moderne que
15 ans tony times comment tu comment tu
vois la chose avec surtout pas un joueur
qui soit qu'elles ont du ballon parce
que si l'option de garder dit angelo
russell qui et les proches de certains
vendus frontoffice tu se confirme un
meneur de jeu faisant de la balle pour
jouer ou couramment de garder le ballon
ce sera très compliqué non partir plus
sur un sur quelqu'un qui serait sur la
création et sur l'exécution plus
quelqu'un malheur comme dans la balle
beaucoup beaucoup pour scorer notamment
où partir voilà sur quelque chose qui
permettrait de renforcer un petit peu la
rotation la rotation intérieure où
s'affairent spx est plus délicate est
donc meilleur d'elles-mêmes trainer l'
angola ce type je pense en considérant
qu'il faut par un petit chêne forcément
la balle donc à ce niveau là nous on a
sorti notre mode draft en fin de semaine
là on à anthony edwards son numéro un
qui a un poste 2-3 rémy pour toi
deangelo russell loin du ballon ça n'a
pas forcément fait ses preuves je pense
à son passage à gauche
une state notamment s'est passé pas son
meilleur rôle et coûte 10 ans de jeu
russell c'est un mec qui a montré des
trucs fantastiques à brooklyn qui a eu
plus de mal à éclore
j'ai envie de croire en lui et moi c'est
un mec qui je crois que j'aime beaucoup
et je pense que bien accompagner cet axe
cette espèce d'axa en cinq là avec arles
antholz peut fonctionner donc si vous me
trouvez un poste 2-3 mettre là-dedans
anthony edwards
je pense que le fit il est logique bon
on valide le gm a choisi façon et le
directeur du footing est d'accord donc
j'ai rien fait anthony edwards somme
yonne je vais rien dire je les gardais
voilà c'est vrai top gun une urgence ces
stations festation oui on la connaît on
a fait à chaque fois
oui oui bien sûr nation donc anthony
edwards
chez les hommes c'est parfait monsieur 2
minutes 50 rémy en directions métiers du
jeu ne fait rien c'est toi le maître des
lieux pic numéro deux à golden state
justement on en parlait à l'instant
hélas hélas le choix ça va être plutôt
très you keep déjà ça va être un gros un
gros choix à faire de la part du front
office riz ouais je pense que là ils
doivent bien se gratter la tête là bob
myers et tout le staff le choix le choix
logique le choix évident ce sera après
pourquoi pas ce que parce que si tu
trade un pic qui a beaucoup de valeur tu
peux avoir un joueur très solide calibre
all star en retour et tu dis qu'avec les
allées deux trois ou quatre à belles
années de steve que ridley thompson qui
reste tu peux encore aller chercher des
bagues une ou plusieurs
donc ça c'est évidemment hyper tentant
une part dans maintenant connaissant la
culture de la culture de l'intelligence
de la construction qu'il existe dans
cette franchise depuis quelques années
je me dis qu'ils vont peut-être être
tenté par le moyen terme aussi tu vois
pour penser à déjà à l'après steve curie
et dans trois ans essayait de trouver le
futur visage de cette franchise en fait
parce que parce que cette cure il a 32
ans et dans trois quatre ans ça va
commencer à décliner un petit peu donc
pourquoi pas réfléchir à quelqu'un
pourquoi pas un poste intérieur qui est
quand même traditionnellement un manque
dans cette franchise
si ça ne trahis pas je les verrais bien
allé chercher un gros talent de
disponible peut-être tourné vers
l'intérieur
peut-être tourné vers l'intérieur alors
romain est ce que tu vois des profils
qui correspondent à sa est ce que est ce
qu'il ya des joueurs qui peuvent avoir
et un impact tout de suite aidé à aller
chercher pourquoi pas le titre l'année
prochaine où aller loin en playoffs et
aussi de venir développer un talent pour
devenir la face d'une franchise dans le
top 10 dans top 10 de prévu on a on a
while the man et au congo
après on sait pour les joueurs
intérieurs ça prend toujours un petit
peu plus de temps donc voir si voir si
le développement de ces joueurs là père
métis casse tout de suite ça va être une
une vraie question je pense en ce qu on
est quand même sur deux sur deux profils
wiseman ca de 13o kong où c'est assez un
peu plus petits c'est la 2 6 c'est un
petit peu en dehors ça peut correspondre
au jeu aux jeunes c'est aussi qu'ils
aient vraiment axé sur la mobilité
après après ce que c'est après ce que
ces prêts je suis désolé pour la
redondance syllabique mais ce que ces
prêts tout de suite à a relevé de a
relevé le défi et à être efficaces pour
une équipe qui serait candidate au titre
ça paraît sa part un tout petit peu un
tout petit peu complexe quand même c'est
pour ça que le trade band
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas un trade en
s'intéressant rémy juste il n'a pas
évoqué comme option mais tu le trail
tout seul le picou il ya un endroit où
wiggins qui est là je pense que ça
dépend des package que tu peux obtenir
en retour
considérant que toute façon les voyants
sont quoi qu'il arrive un obstacle
d'incroyable pour l'année prochaine
parce que tu vas retrouver cette afrique
et thomson dream green et toute la
clique talent option tu continues
tentait avec andrew higgins et ton petit
numéro 2 août à l'aube son site à là
pour le coup si tu trade andrew higgins
plus un pic numéro deux lattes a
clairement un joueur de calibre all star
en retour donc ça dépend de ce qu'on me
propose en échange
évidemment mais j'en sais rien imagine
que tu veuilles blindés tomba courte et
ferrarone pour aller chercher bradley
bill par exemple
andrew higgins plus le pic de comptes
bradley bill tu te retrouves avec les
thompson steve que rivera de l'ebit une
paire d'arrières incroyable enfin trois
arrières en l'occurrence très maniable
sait combien ça me paraît compliqué au 6
mai mais est ce qu'ils ont accompli à
défendre je veux dire c'est compliqué de
dire après la courte mais c'est
compliqué est-ce qu'ils sont pas
capables de faire jouer les trois
ensemble moi je pense que c'est
totalement leur amabilité dangereux qui
font totalement parce que c'est comme
une équipe qui qui est tout à fait
capable de jouer ce sont vraies mais
l'heure de jeu spécifique de par la
création que la porte est donc ça peut
être ça peut tout à fait cohérent mais
si la cloche la cloche sonne il faut
faire un choix est ce qu'on est ce qu'on
doive d'un grand où est-ce qu'on traîne
le pic pompon pour moi très grande parce
que effectivement sur les poses 2 3 2 3
4 parce que bon si c'est vraiment une
joute un rôle de faux 4 comme il fait
comme si parfois c'est comme déjà chargé
donc je raconte te dire tu rates tu peux
me tromper mais je partirai là dessus et
je valide la vie de mon scoop de mon
chef du scouting
je pense que les warriors ou encore de
belles années avec cette écurie est que
thomson reut c'est peut-être dommage
il n'est pas temps de réfléchir à la
suite réfléchissez au court terme vous
pouvez aller chercher des bacs de tri de
la notion à les intrigues d'années on va
chercher au congo qui est plus
warriors compatible je pense que que
james wyman
le pic numéro 3 est arrivé à charlotte
qui a fait une superbe opération puisque
il entre dans le top 3 alors qu'il avait
chez plus le 7 ou 8e meilleure chance
d'avoir le petit numéro un qu'est ce
qu'on fait à charlotte donc à charlotte
on a démonté g on a des jeunes avec
miles bridge fidji washington mais pas
vraiment de supers stars n'ont
clairement ils manquent ils manquent de
star power dans cette équipe là il ya il
ya une construction une reconstruction
qui est en train de se faire et dont on
fait les frais ni combat tout par
exemple qui est logique à charlotte
on donne les clés du camion à des ventes
et g pourquoi pas mais c'est une équipe
qui manque clairement de talents
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'autour de
deux des ventes et g t'as pas un mec qui
se détache où tu te dis que tu peux
construire avec la préquelle ben walker
est un peu compliqué là donc là
dans un schéma hyper simple hyper clair
je pense où il faut vraiment
foncièrement aller chercher le plus gros
talents disponibles
peu importe la durée du talent donc
romain que conseils tu à ce niveau-là de
la draft lie à lui donnant joie il ya du
choix on aura là mais lowball au noir
coraux on aura quillanais lille on aura
déjà il ya quand même quelques quelques
quelques quelques quelques quelques
prospects quand même max est un petit
peu plus bas au chi il reste trois jeux
6 1
il resterait voyage manu la coi on a on
a le choix on a le choix sur différents
sur différentes poses de jeu on a dit on
a du créateur on a toujours du petit
canard hall il ya un petit peu de tout
un petit peu tout reste à voir après ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut très
spécifiquement mais il ya un petit peu
tout renier la mélo bol c'est ça veut
dire aussi forcément du marketing autour
de l'équipe ça veut dire de l'attrait
plus fort des médias c'est quelque chose
qui peut peser dans une décision de
franchise bien sûr bien sûr que ça peut
peser surtout pour une franchise comme
charlotte qui est un petit peu
alors si c'est une franchise étrange
charlotte parce que c'est une franchise
qu'on considère comme historique alors
qu'au final jamais rien gagné mais mais
c'est sa logo qui marque c'est ça un nom
qui parle aux gens aussi et c'est une
franchise qui a besoin je pense dans un
état où quand même le ca pue le basket
la caroline du nord et c'est une équipe
c'est une franchise qui a besoin
d'exister et je suis assez d'accord avec
toi là dessus c'est à dire que il avait
fait ça par le passé tu sais en draft en
deshawn mais où des raymond felton des
mec du coin pour essayer justement de
redonner cette couleur basket et je
pense qu'un la mélo bol et ben ça peut
mettre un coup de projecteur sur le truc
je me suis j'ai l'impression non plus
que ça pourrait marcher avec des ventes
et g
la meinau où el amel au bol c'est plus
un roman là on l'a vu cette année un
porteur de balle pour l'instant et des
ventes et g et il est créateur
secondaire j'allais dire c'est à dire
choper la balle une fois qu'il ya déjà
un décalage ou même profité de son tir
pour tourner autour des écrans en
courant donc ça peut être pas mal roman
qu'est ce t'en penses
koh lanta n'est trop loin mais l'idée du
local aurait pu correspondre avec lui
mais colantonio trop et alors il ya
tellement d'incertitudes que moi y
vivent mais c'est vrai que nous nous en
tout cas on le voyait pas avoir un
calibre de joueur qui peut être
numéro 1 d'une équipe moi ça ça me
parait ça me paraît cohérent puis la
rencontre entre entre bôle ball p1
michael jordan après les quelques
petites sorties qui ont eu en terme de
treize villes de la part du père bol ça
peut être ce petit quelque chose
d'amusant d'allusions avoir repensé sur
la première son de presse c'est vrai
qu'on va avoir de honte d'avoir dû
lavables et michael jordan ensemble à
l'écran afin de faire sur un contre un
c'est validé c'est validé la mélo ball
aux hornets tient pas sur contre du
monde je pense
les bulls ont le choix numéro 4 à l'az
les boules c'est très intéressant parce
qu'il ya plein de joueurs justement qui
ont du potentiel
qu'est-ce qui est ce qu'on est ce qu'on
joue le côté fit en allant chercher
peut-être plus un ailier ou un meilleur
créateur ou est ce qu'on va chercher du
talent d'aaland du talent écoute tu as
raison chicago c'est une équipe
intéressante parce que déjà déjà ils
sont recherche de coach on va voir ce
qui va se passer tu vois il ya une
rotation qui se fait là dessus donc ça
va changer beaucoup la donne mais en
termes de l'effectif de noyaux pur et
dur quand je regarde un petit peu là je
me suis mis leur sort sous les yeux j'ai
de plus en plus de mal à croire que tu
me parler d'un ailier en autoporteur moi
je pense que c'est une franchise qui a
besoin de continuer à construire autour
de zac l'avim qui doit en rester là bas
pour moi qui ai bien et de laurie
markkanen en qui je crois toujours tout
le monde sait que j'aime bien c'est mon
petit chouchou et je suis persuadé qu'un
jour ou l'autre il a également des
allures cannelle et je te mettrai un
poste 3 solides la dent en plus quand je
vois là où on tombe il ya des noms
solide de poster trois costauds quoi
donc allé me chercher un poste 3 solides
aux mains ça confirme là on est on a du
poste 3 la schola de la draft si on
considère qu'il ya un ras le bol wiseman
et edward ce prix avant il ya du monde
on peut et on pourrait chercher du couac
est ce que jésus patrick williams donc
ce qu'on a j'aurais patrick williams et
serait un reach ce niveau là mais
rihanna qui considère que c'est un des
plus gros potentiels de la draft un add
on la devine mais on a des lignes va
seul qui est disponible aussi aux coraux
est toujours là encore huit jours là je
sache ne devienne pas pensé
à ce niveau là ce serait pas bah ça peut
l'être après moi j'ai peur d'une chose
sur le j'aime beaucoup laurie marque à
l'anoci
mais j'avais peur d'une chose c'est là
la combinaison avait déjà mark allen
dans un ensemble sur le terrain j'ai
peur de l'impact des fonds six mois
parce que même si le riz marque heden à
une vraie évolution sur ce sur ce côté
là je me demande s'ils rêvent déjà
aujourd'hui a les moyens d'aller
vraiment cherché et tenir du du 3
explosif c'est un petit peu la question
n'en a parlé peu plus tard car c'est un
petit peu la question qu'on a par
rapport à lui de talent en attaque on
l'a le côté grande gueule un petit peu
showman et compagnie il n'y a pas de
souci s'il peut tout à fait tout à fait
citer mois titre perçoit près voilà j'ai
toujours cette petite petite inquiétude
petite inquiétude avec l'huile davantage
par contre d'être dans un contexte comme
chicago ces cas les actes levine avec
partager avec des joueurs déjà installés
autour il a pas forcément date dans les
premières première option offensive
donc ce que ça peut lui permettre une
transition un peu plus un peu plus en
douceur vers vers la nba sur ce qu'il a
montré des choses en euroligue cette
année c'était parfois un petit peu en
dents de scie mais bon il ya des choses
il ya des choses à faire en sachant que
c'est un joueur qui en euroligue a même
sorti son épingle du jeu des deux côtés
du car malgré tout ils descendent des
landes est un peu tout mais c'est vrai
quand on le voit plus défendre des
quatre avec une nba de plus en plus
petites en plus voilà c'est un petit peu
un petit peu le questionnement qu'on a
par rapport à lui mais la valeur basket
fait que c'est tout à fait correct puis
ça c'est un profil pour ce 3 c'est
complet qui qui peut coller avec ce que
avec les besoins créés
après vous savez quoi il ya un truc
c'est con mais ça existe toujours en nba
mais je me rends bien compte à force de
côtoyer les mecs il ya toujours dans
beaucoup de franchise cette espèce de
frilosité à aller chercher des européens
qui existe encore aujourd'hui en 2020 et
le fait qu'ils aient fait ce pari depuis
un moment maintenant markkanen qui a un
talent fou mais qui met quand même du
temps à atteindre ce potentiel convoyant
lui il ya quelques temps et ce qu'ils
sont prêts à retenter le coup avec ave
déjà j'en sais rien il y en ad'autres un
an disait vasselle vasselle okoro
williams et trois gros défenseur alors
patrick williams sera plus sur le post
4 mai mais okoro c'est plus gros
défenseurs de cette draft et de loin ça
manque de shoot mais en même temps il y
en a au tour pour le coup à chicago
c'est pas forcément duval bon on valide
aux coraux on va c'est validé au gold
hawk auront tôt
allez ça va aller on passe au choix
numéro 5
on enchaîne et le numéro cinq s'est les
caps qui sont fait un peu avoir
puisqu'il était dans les trois équipes
avec le plus de chances d'avoir une
source piqué bon ben on peut les
perdants de cette loterie mais en même
temps dans cette draft c'est un niveau
assez homogène sur sur les topics qu'on
va dire donc c'est pas si grave qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec ce choix numéro 5
qu'ils ont misé sur des talents à
l'arrière lors des dernière draft mais
et s'il considère qu'un arrière est le
plus fort est ce que quand même ils
doivent de rester un arrière skis drafté
le meilleur talent disponible mais c'est
une équipe qui aujourd'hui est quand
même dans un processus qu'on a tous du
mal à comprendre en termes de
construction c'est une équipe qui met
des points qui a du talent à l'arrière
tu l'as dit sexton garlande ok très bien
qui a fait des traits qui a fait venir
hormones on sait pas trop pourquoi on
sait pas combien de temps il va rester
là kevin love on sait pas combien de
temps il va rester là tristane thompson
aussi donc je pense que c'est une équipe
qui doit se focaliser sur vraiment sur
l'essence du jeu et ce qui leur manque
clairement en terme d'essence à cette
équipe-là au calme c'est la défense
c'est une équipe qui aujourd'hui n'a pas
de défense parce que entre être bonne
mais il n'est pas là seulement terme a
donc moi ce que j'aimerais bien c'est
vous me trouviez un mec qui sait
défendre là dedans et idéalement pas sur
les postes arrières parce qu'on a quand
même bien remplie la donne depuis deux
ans aux mains là on a un peu les mêmes
noms qui reviennent par rapport à la
dernière fois où ou des intérieurs aux
siens parce que en avoir on en a on à
okoro donc toujours pas moins de choix
partie donc je suis en train c'est la
saison mais sinon passer la nacelle
c'est peut-être le meilleur défenseur of
the ball de cette draft résidence el
bassel ça peut ça peut tout à fait
coller oui ça peut tout à fait coller
c'est pas c'est pas mal du tout on peut
on peut partir sur ce profil là parce
que - près du hobbit opine ça me paraît
d'être activement ses bases basse en
ciment s'est passé face à ça
offensivement c'est costaud patrick
patrick williams ça peut switcher ça
peut les fonds des joueurs plus grand
que lui aussi les bons particulier
aiment ça et 19 ans et encore un petit
peu la route à faire mais bon voilà
vaste elle va c'est le william ça me
paraît ce sera peut-être un petit peu
plus haut que ce qu'on pensait mais ça
me paraît correspondre un des deux de
florida state donc puisque les deux
étaient coéquipiers cette année rémi ça
te plait un joueur toit sont à demander
un joueur qui défend un joueur qui donne
une identité à cette équipe et avec 1h
taille dans les deux zones
bien sûr le bus se disent assez trouver
de la défense à cette équipe là avoue
mois idéalement dans un monde parfait
comme je vous dis que je croit pas en
l'avenir d'autres modes kevin love les
mêmes systèmes thompson vous m'auriez
trouver un intérieur solide qui défend
j'aurais pris mais si vous me trouvez un
poste trois gros défenseur jeu promotion
après ici dans notre projection là il
reste james wyman qui est un gros talent
qui était vu numéro 1 bsa c et ben il
protège le cerf est est-ce qui peut
défendre sur au périmètre comme disait
dit notre ami ben québécois c'est moins
sûr la difficulté c'est qu'il a peu joué
cette année qu'on parle d'un gamin qui a
19 ans et qui à 2,13 donc avec une
projection qui à mon avis sera sur
plusieurs saisons donc là dans ce cas là
si tu pars sur un wiseman tu pars sûr
que c'est un cada capacité à faire les
choses mais par contre qu'ils avaient
peut-être demander aussi plus de
patience en termes de temps de
reconstruction
est-ce que ce que laisse que les caps
aujourd'hui sont là dedans peut-être
peut-être en fait c'est ça le truc c'est
que ils savent très bien qu'ils ont
honte que dans les trois ans qui
viennent ils vont rien à jouer donc est
ce qui serait pas intelligent d'aller
chercher ce mec-là s'il a vraiment un si
gros potentiel que ça c'est plus mobile
qu'un cpu mobiles car whiteside par
exemple sur quelque chose quelque chose
qui peut être intéressant donc dans ce
cas là oui wiseman peut être vous pouvez
être peut coller puisque mon prêt à 2,13
et avec une motricité intéressante
il est dans les standards de le domaine
dit aujourd'hui certes c'est pas du b 13
l'ours et d'une tresse très mobiles
d'autant plus si vous le coller dans les
pattes au début si vous me dites qu'il
est pas une pierre et dit tout de suite
vous le coller dans les pas de date
remonte à tristane thompson
avec un peu dur au mal et tout match ça
peut être pas mal moi je pense ça peut
en sachant que ça dépendra jamais moins
qu'un leurs demandes de toute façon le
pseye play et le tacle pour vendre et
donc pour les cavs
on va partir sur le choix numéro 6 ans
enchaîne ont pris un peu de retard et ce
sont les hawks ce sont les hawks
d'atlanta avec le choix numéro 6
intéressant très intéressante la
situation d'atlanta rémy qu'est ce que
tu en penses
c'est une franchise qui a un bel avenir
attentats je pensais qu'ils auraient
même pu faire quelque chose dès cette
année ça n'a pas été le cas je continue
de penser que sur l'année qui vient où
les deux trois années qui viennent ils
ont ils ont quand même tout ce qu'il
faut pour pour revenir sur le devant de
la scène
maintenant soit en restant pragmatique
en se rendant compte un petit peu de ce
qui est ce qu'ils ont dans un magasin on
voit clairement qu'il ya deux équipes à
atlanta une équipe avec triangle sur le
parquet une équipe centre ayant que sur
le parquet il ya du talent partout il ya
john collins et à kevin walter il ya des
mecs pour devenir très fort mais mais ça
manque de cette capacité à scorer en
dehors de triangle c'est trop triangle
dépendant donc moi ce que j'aimerais
bien avec un pic si je pense qu'il ya
moyen de trouver des mecs qui savent
mettre des paniers quoi j'ai besoin de
quelqu'un qui peut mettre des points moi
j'ai une petite idée d'un joueur qu'on
connaît bien quoi qui serait un peu du
cru pays romand et il ya nice en france
ça peut t'il analyse atlanta il ya un
facteur qui rentrent en ligne de compte
c'est qu'il ait des changements sur le
front office et je crois que le
directeur du scouting qui avaient ou
l'assistant gm je supplie les deux cas
participer ainsi pour la reconstruction
de la recréation tu es parti donc est-ce
que ça va pas changer un petit peu la
perspective de ella qui est la qualité
du boulot ça reste toujours quelque
chose à voir des petits lyonnais je peux
rentrer dans quelque chose dans quelque
chose qui corresponde eh oui
effectivement à ces choses là parce que
dès aujourd'hui un tiers attire sur le
pouleuf un step back qui sont efficaces
qui permettent deux après qui viennent
c'est pas vraiment c'est pas vraiment
d'eux c'est un petit peu entre les deux
est ce qu'avec très en deçà play
compatible parce que les deux ont quand
même beau dans la balle un client n'a
besoin du ballon pour exister
sissako existe on peut être sûr un bac
courte qui peut se défendre n'est pas ce
bo1 il peut défendre des postes le sait
jamais hein
c'est jamais ça ne sera jamais le
défenseur de l'année par contre leur
capacité à lire anticipé à voler des
ballons à courir il a progressé de la
revue joué cette saison avec cool il a
progressé par rapport à l'an dernier
avec avec cholet
voilà il ya les qualités loustics
toujours un petit peu un petit peu en
question mais bon il avance et ce qui
vaut aux états unis puis depuis quelques
mois maintenant qu'ils bossent c'est un
contexte sans trop de pression qu'on
peut presque lui souhaiter dans une
équipe qui risque de bien rouler qui a
de l'avenir et c'est ouais ouais
puis avec avec avec quelqu'un voilà avec
avec rayons qui peut tenir la balle à
côté donc c'est partage des
responsabilités dans un jeu moderne sans
vraie post revin avec 2 avec deux combos
qui sera pas qu'il sera pas une
intéressant pourquoi pas ça serait un
peu se veut ni d ailleurs émis tu
achètes je prends je prends qu'il aille
là-bas et puis ce serait une petite
fierté puisque tu te retrouves avec un
français dans une équipe qui a priori un
bel avenir devant elle c'est pas cher
c'est pas quelqu'un qui débarqua clients
d'aujourd'hui où c'est un peu le bazar
très chouette pour lui et donc ça serait
avec le choix 6 le français choisit le
clos de l'histoire si c'est si notre
scénario confiance qui est fortement peu
probable on va être honnête détroit avec
le pic sept detroit une situation
délicate
une équipe que tu aimes bien romain mais
c'est une rémy qu'il a dressé le constat
la situation là on est clairement à l'
inverse de ce que tu le disais tu vois
quand vous parlez d'atlanta ajouté
qu'une équipe ya appel à pour les
pistols on est typiquement dans le cas
d'une franchise qui est dans une galère
absolue reconstruction on sait pas dans
quel sens ça va
les griffin s'est plus l'avenir on sait
de cette franchise
ils ont laissé filer drôme on se demande
vraiment qui a les clés là dedans dans
cet effectif
j'ai beau chercher du talent sur tous
les postes vraiment sincèrement c'est
horrible que je vais dire mais j'ai du
mal à en trouver
je pense que c'est un peu dur pour eux
surtout avec le pic sept îles ont aimé
sans doute choisir un peu plus haut mais
mais avec ce qu'il y aura disponibles
aspic là il faut prendre un mec qui a du
talent le plus gros talent possible peu
importe le poste
c'est la situation la situation est très
compliquée monde les griffes il continue
sa transition vers le stand up
si vous cherchez un petit peu sur
youtube il ya ya pas mal de vidéos sur
le sujet mais y'a plus rien alors faut
espérer que l'arrivée du nouveau gm
remettre un petit peu d'ordre dans la
maison d'une franchise complètement à la
dérive comme plus gros talents qu'est ce
qu'on a comme plus gros alors là là
c'est vraiment le moment de la draft où
ça peut partir à n'importe où c'est à
dire qu'un point serait bien qu'on saura
nous 20e nous il peut il peut partir en
on a en a qu'on a on en a dans l'analyse
max et qui reste encore cheer lewis à
l'arrière du cou pour les deux on avait
déjà qui est toujours pas pris du coup
on a ça me patrick williams qui est un
obstacle m haies et au now by thomas
hobi tobin puis si on va chercher plus
loin d'intégrale terry encore qui vont
sera peut-être une surprise de le voir
aussi moment là on arange de 6,7 joueurs
assez large à detroit l'alberta ouest
je voyais la baule il ya vrai c'est ça
on parlera moins en moins là mais bon
c'est mon truc l'an dernier l'an dernier
j'étais un peu surpris des va reprendre
ses coûts aussi aux personnellement je
ne sais pas ce qu'ils peuvent aller
chercher aujourd'hui est ce que
l'expérience c'est qu'on va pas l'air
froid
effectivement deux pour un européen ça
peut aussi être un point et ça c'est le
nerf est de facto quelques quelques noms
qui pourraient traîner un endroit
bellemare ou des joueurs comme ça même
si ça fait un petit peu haut pour lui
donc c'est obino biteau pin's est
peut-être passé peut-être pas incohérent
parce que on de l'attak
immédiatement on va dire de la croix la
création offensive voilà il a il a
peut-être on peut peut-être capitaliser
sur lui tout de suite avoir ben ali
dont cette histoire d'hôpitaux pin moi
je me parler d'un mec qui est je pense
et plus sur les postes intérieurs
ouais je pense qu'il est intéressant
pour eux de façon d'avoir un mec qui
puisse faire quelque chose tout de suite
l'expérience s'écoula doumbouya qui va
peut-être exploser un jour ou l'autre
très bien mais je pense que vu l'état de
l'équipe ils ont besoin d'un mec surtout
avec un flic élevé comme ça ils ont
besoin d'un mec qui peut jouer dès
l'année prochaine en nba mois bon et
bien aux beats au pin et donc choisi par
détroit on passe à new york
tiens marque soit numéro 8 qu'est ce
qu'on fait à new york rémy j'allais dire
de la merde comme d'hab mais sa peine
leurs pages grand format et coûte déjà
j'ai l'impression que les knicks ont
tenté de faire le ménage sur le front
office et c'était la base de tout est ce
que ce sera cognitive j'en sais rien
mais au moins ils tentent quelque chose
l'arbre au début parce qu'on sait très
bien que le front office précédents
n'étaient pas au niveau
c'est une équipe qui a des attentes
perpétuelle qui déçoit de manière
régulière qui aujourd'hui à un seul mec
indiscutable dans le roster et qu'il
faut pas toucher ces rejets par tout le
reste c'est amovible christiane robinson
peut-être ouais si michelle robinson tu
as raison michelle robinson aussi sans
que ce soit un indiscutable non plus
c'est pas j'aime beaucoup ce mec là mais
il sera pas onstar un jour j'en doute
fortement
je pense que c'est une équipe qui a
besoin de faire le ménage sur le poste
de meneur ça me fait mal au coeur de
dire ça parce que je fais partie de ceux
qui croient encore en francs cnil qui
n'a et je suis persuadé que franck à sa
place régulier mais juste pas aux knicks
il faut lui trouver un spot ailleurs
elle free payton dennis mise tout ça
c'est l'expérience la ce genre de mec là
moi je pense qu'il est temps de se
passer le balai là dedans si vous aviez
un bon meneur de jeu disponibles je
prendrai tout de suite alors romain là
on a tyrese maxi keira lewis c'est nos
deux préférés au niveau de l'équipe à ce
niveau-là de la draft
d'autres aiment bien tyrese halliburton
ou un peu moins qu est ce que tu penses
des deux profils tu aimais bien maxi là
j'avais beaucoup maxi j'ai bien maxi moi
je pense je pense parenthèse que dénié
avait déjà pour plein de raisons
pourraient faire un pique pas une
intéressant pour les nietzsche mais avec
une pré pression sur les sur les épaules
et pif c'est peut-être pas forcément ce
qu'il leur faut en terme de en terme de
fuites mais il y aurait quelque chose
l'a fait en termes d'image
après tyrese maximois ça me parait ça me
paraît plutôt plutôt plutôt intéressant
et c'est peut-être le le premier nom qui
viendrait sur la meilleure de jeu après
ces jeunes est ce que ça peut tout de
suite collé à la pression qui va voir à
new york c'est compliqué ce qu'il
faudrait pas qu'à un moment ou un autre
les knicks contre chant marché et sur
les joueurs du scoop pour aller chercher
un meneur de jeu un peu un peu plus
expérimenté dans une équipe en
construction permanente à voir mais je
rejoins l'avis sur le fait qu'il ya une
alors ménage à faire de toute façon si
ça doit passer par le poste 1 sachant
qu'ils sont viables chez les robinson
ils peuvent construire un axe instinct
qui effectivement dans ce cas la foi et
sur terry ce maxi qui pour moi le poster
de plus intéressant
allez tyrese maxi onyx on passe à
washington avec le choix numéro 9 comme
l'année dernière vous allez choisir hui
hachey mourra que va-t-on faire cette
saison du côté des wizards
là aussi c'est une franchise qui se pose
beaucoup de questions washington c'est
encore une franchise qui a déçu laqué
qui est venu dans la bulle au final on
sait pas trop pourquoi et qui qui a
pourtant tellement de talent de passe
dans son équipe c'est incroyable de
l'avoir galéré à ce point là c'était on
va être pragmatique encore une fois à
john ball il est intraitable avec son
contrat on le sait il bougera pas la
question c'est est ce qui reviendra à
jour à son niveau
j'ai envie de croire que oui qu'est ce
qu'on fait de bradley bill est ce que se
décide enfin être aidés ou est-ce qu'au
contraire washington continue de miser
sur ce balles courtes john ball bradley
been maintenant en valeur d'avenir
intéressante à rui h il y auras ta
thomasg bryant qui propose pas mal de
trucs
même si ça défend pas comme comme comme
on pourrait le vouloir tu as peut-être
sur le poste 3 écoute moi je serais
d'avis
ne pas toucher au bac courte de laisser
john wall et pas débiles qui toute
manière sur deux superstars et aura pas
mieux aujourd'hui quand et washington je
serais d'avis d'aller renforcer soit le
poste 3 soit d'aller me trouver un
intérieur qui soit un peu plus défensif
la tomate brian et bien on a on à
patrick williams qui est pas là on a un
patrick williams qui est pas mal qui est
pas mal c'est cesser florida state c'est
ce qui sort quelques quelques joueurs
ces dernières années ses sabots savic et
de défendre sur des athlètes souvent ça
peut les fournitures plusieurs postes
voilà on fonce et son ami sur le
billboard c'est qu'on projette lui
globalement entre 8e et 20e parce que on
sait on sait à peu près où il en est on
sait on sait pas trop jusqu'où il peut
aller
mais bon ça peut ça peut être
intéressant à patrick williams sur lui
au revoir c'est à la fois un pari
d'avenir est à la fois sa porte de la
défense tout de suite la défense entre
les durées delà de la polyvalence
défensive
c'est vrai ce don bryant et hachey mora
où un peu plus de mal à faire de ce côté
là du terrain rémy 7 ça te branche way
écoute surtout que vous en parlait
depuis ta leur salade être un talent
s'il encore disponibles sur le pit 9 qui
est intéressant à prendre à ce niveau là
donc jour de la draft
ouais c'est je crois que c'est le
deuxième plus jeune après pau qui c'est
ce qui est l'europe est un des seuls on
termine par les suns 10e qui sortent
d'un superbe épisode dans la bulle avec
avec des vignes coeur avec l'écriture
bio avec diane drayton qui s'améliore de
jour en jour que fair que faire si on
est les seuls à ça c'est une bonne
question parce que là pour le coup c'est
quand même la belle surprise de cette
fin de saison
phoenix personnes les avait vus aussi
beau aussi vite
c'est vraiment pour le coup une
franchise qui est dans un super état là
qui a basculé complètement son son
avenir en huit matches dans la bulle
tu as du talent à tous les postes tu as
dit andré tonnes bien sûr pas des vignes
booker évidemment ils ont créé un cam
johnson à qui est titulaire sur la mule
l'acquis et qui devenu très fort chaud
une calbry 10 en 3 très fort mais qui
marche bien ricky rubio s'est tellement
devenu de mais ricky rubio depuis son sa
coupe du monde l'année dernière il est
devenu incroyable je trouve cette venue
c'est devenu la force tranquille quoi
qu'il fasse c'est bien tout le temps et
qui se pique donc du coup il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de besoin évident moi
je me demande si plus intéressant de là
dedans ce serait pas d'aller chercher un
meneur backup
malheureusement et pourtant je les adore
c'est pas vraiment un honneur mais mais
mais j'ai l'impression que ce même
évident qu'ils croient plus au rugby au
cobo les suns et qu'à chaque fois que
ricky rubio sortait du parquet ou été
blessé il y avait une baisse de niveau
j'irais bien cherché un meneur bas qu un
mec qui peut aussi du coup jouer un peu
au football parce que recréer apprend
aussi de la place et très de plus en
plus avec de ce genre même si même si
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont venus
l'expérience se fait pendant un temps il
y avait ce fantasme des vignes booker ce
n'est que rien on va le mettre mineur
lui aussi et ils en sont revenus de ça
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont rendu
compte que ça marchait pas donc ouais
donc on a du tir à lewis et du tyrese
halliburton qui est plus bas mais qui
peut jouer un peu au football ce qui est
aussi intéressant et qui est peut-être
projeté meilleur of the ball roman parce
qu'on a vendu le terrain thierry dejean
nom d altérer ce serait au programme
intéressant très intéressant sa dernière
dans la vraie vie c'est pour ça ça peut
être dans le style de jeu à l'ouest ça
peut ça peut être intéressant auxi tiers
à lewis et être le choix le plus le plus
le plus logique du la hauteur de pique
ça me paraît simple paraît cohérent dans
ce cas là après voilà attention tous les
aspects défensifs
ouais si tu es du shoot shoot shoot te
conseille des welters et me dit je suis
même pas sûr avec des bimbos coeur à
côté ce que tu as besoin d'un mec qui
met dedans forcément c'est toujours bien
c'est toujours bon à prendre mais je
pense qu'un bon meneur gestionnaire dans
le style d'un ricky rubio
ça m'irait bien bah du coup halliburton
seul burton allez on se parle
halliburton et on a fini ce top 10 dans
les temps messieurs c'est parfait il
nous reste 10 minutes dans cette réunion
zoom qui met la pression avec le petit
panneau moins d'une minute merci
beaucoup rémy pour le plaisir les gars
toujours cool d'être avec vous pour
discuter draft un petit peu on parlera
avec romain et tout ça de ce qu'on va
faire sur le bim a bon on sait pas que
ça tombe très bien parce qu'on joue à
nanterre
juste un moment bompard fait marcher le
timing est bon
parfait eh bien merci messieurs et on se
retrouve nous très bientôt sur envergure
pour évoquer cette grâce qui arrive avec
avec des profils de joueurs du premier
du second tour on vous a tout fait on va
tout mettre sur le site aussi envergure
point c'est au cha tout le monde